an automated car one that relies on
sensors and complex algorithms to
navigate is a challenge that many
companies are tackling but if an
automated car was only designed to
transport goods and not people how might
it look
they don't have steering wheels they
don't have pedals they don't have seats
there's no way for a person to sit
inside of this vehicle it is completely
focused on goods wired spoke to neuro's
chief technology officer and design head
to learn how they engineered their
robotic delivery vehicle
this is neuro
an automated delivery vehicle
we've now gone through three generations
of vehicle development and we learned so
much from you know even just some of the
hardware design elements or the way that
the vehicle operated on roads or how it
interacted with our autonomy stack
companies around the world are
developing robotic delivery vehicles to
aim at cutting down on our local trips
picking up groceries and delivering food
the team tackled two challenges when
making the robot getting the technology
right and designing a car from scratch
it starts here
with their arch so here you can see a
main lidar which has 360 degree view of
the world creates a really robust point
cloud for our system to use to know
exactly where everything is around it
and i would describe it as the ears
and the eyes of the vehicle we have a
camera detects traffic lights and then
we have 360 cameras all the way around
as well part of the reason why we have
that distinctive arch is so that we can
pack all of that long-range sensing
technology into an integrated sensor pod
it also means if we want to upgrade the
sensor pod we can do that without
completely tearing up all the beautiful
body panels that you made in the rest of
the vehicle the team debuted their first
design the r1 in 2018. so r1 we built
that within the very first year of the
company even existing from ideation to
design it was a really rapid really fast
program to get r1 up and running we
learned a lot about the capacity that we
need in the vehicle so we had to adapt
the cargo volume to make sure we fit 24
bags of groceries and and get all the
way up to 500 pounds of cargo volume one
of the things we changed with r2 was
having the doors go a bit higher or some
tall folks would bunk their head on the
top of the the shorter doors on r1 with
r2 we wanted to make a fleet of these
and so we really took our time to really
detail design a custom electric vehicle
chassis with a little bit of a different
body panel set up so that we could
actually make a large fleet of these in
their latest model the team honed in on
designing a car that was friendly to
pedestrians but suited for the road the
front face was designed to evoke a
friendliness the lights for example
they're circular they look friendly a
little cut off on the top so they has a
sense of urgency as well right because
we want to be friendly we want to be
inviting but we also don't want to
communicate you know what
take five six seven ten minutes unload
your groceries because at some point we
have to get to the next person they also
reimagined how the car sounded
[Music]
it took us about six months and with
multiple iterations because you're
designing a sound on a laptop but you
can really just tell how it sounds when
it's on road when it's driving and it
mixes in with the with with the sounds
of the movement we spent a lot of time
on the speaker actually as well but we
realized if you at some point want to
operate in cities and you have a lot of
like background noise you have to have a
much bigger speaker we position
microphones around the vehicle for
detecting emergency vehicle sirens and
so that's what's actually going on back
here so even during the time from r1 to
r2 you saw a really big upgrade in the
sensors that we had on the vehicle and
the same thing is happening now from r2
to the neuro is a massive upgrade both
in the capabilities of the sensors that
we have our lidar our radar our cameras
as well as the compute which is the
brain of the vehicle have all been
upgraded in their latest version the
team added safety features like an
airbag to protect pedestrians that's
what's actually packaged right behind
here in that worst case scenario protect
someone's head and neck and really
minimize the injury to them in that
scenario before they build their
prototypes they start with a wooden
model the wooden model was really the
first functional prototype that we built
of our current vehicle we've
experimented with loading floor height
with the volume of bags that we wanted
to accomplish we take the feedback that
we're getting from the engineering team
and wrap whatever components we receive
mail them out of clay do adjustments by
hand and 3d scan them and put them back
into cat all the way to to tooling
really so it's a really interesting
actually very manual process and what
daniel described is really going from
very low fidelity models to very high
fidelity models you can do that with a
wooden model but it's much more painful
to do that with a full clay model
because once you do that it's expensive
and you don't want to do that multiple
times neuro plans on hiring out their
vehicles to companies who will use their
fleet to deliver everything from
packages to pizza right now the company
is operating on the roads in scottsdale
arizona houston texas and the bay area
with plans to expand nationwide i can't
wait to see over the next five years how
this really scales and starts to get out
and really give people time back
[Music]